zdf heute live ganz herzlich willkommen
an diesem montagabend
die lage ist bitter ernst sagt
bundespräsident frank walter steinmeier
heute morgen zitat von mittwoch an wird
deshalb unser öffentliches und unser
privates leben so stark eingeschränkt
wie noch nie in der geschichte der
bundesrepublik
bevor es soweit ist versuchen alle so
gut und so viel wie möglich noch ihre
weihnachtsgeschenke zu besorgen
zum beispiel in osnabrück heute nochmal
lastminute trubel in der fußgängerzone
und langes warten in den schlangen
ganz anders heute in dresden stille tage
lange vor der stillen nacht denn der
harte schotter und gilt in sachsen schon
heute und auch die friseure schließen
mittwoch bundesweit der run auf den last
minute ist groß dieses geschäft in
delmenhorst ist zu klein deshalb besteht
die lösung im freiluft frisieren bevor
dann übermorgen der harte schnitt für
alle kommt und zwar bundesweit und auch
in hamburg da ist es wenn ricken für uns
wenn die frage mit dem friseur die
stellt sich für dich glücklicherweise
nicht aber für viele andere die um dich
herum in himberg straße unterwegs sind
was hast du denn da heute gesehen und
gehört und wie viel ist da im moment los
und ganz kurz bevor du loslegst wir
sagen noch dazu du trägst die maske ganz
klar weil masken pflicht besteht in der
hamburger innenstadt in teilen der
hamburger innenstadt ich stehe hier in
der spitalerstraße das ist eine der
haupteinkaufsstraßen und ja das mit dem
friseur die frage stellt sich bei mir in
der tat nicht liegt aber auch daran dass
es da kaum mehr termine zu holen gibt
und wenn ich mich mal hier so ein
bisschen bewegen in der einkaufsstraße
dann sieht man hier ist tatsächlich
ziemlich viel los vor manchen
einkaufszentren in hamburg haben sich
mehr als 500 meter lange schlangen
gebildet hier in der innenstadt verteilt
es sich natürlich ein bisschen mehr weil
da ganz viel platz ist nichtsdestotrotz
wenn man sich den tag x an guckt heute
morgen als er begonnen hat ein paar
meter hier drüben standen die leute
schon ab 8
und haben gewartet dass die geschäfte
und 9 uhr öffnen vor den baumärkten
haben sich schlangen gebildet und auch
bei den großen elektronikgeschäften wo
man natürlich last minute geschenke
bekommen kann
da war es ziemlich voll bei mir steht
jetzt hendrik hendrik krebs 9
gucken sie mal zu mir sie haben auch
fleißig muss man die maske wieder
hochziehen es ist hier das möchte ich
noch dazu sagen masken pflicht in der
spitalerstraße deswegen müssen wir die
hier auftrag henrik lassen sie mich
raten sie wollen auch noch
weihnachtsgeschenke kaufen oder warum
sind sie hier
ja es ist offensichtlich und das im
letzten tage sind wo man noch
unbestimmte leben rein kann muss es
heute morgen erledigen
wie stellt sich die situation denn für
sie da war es vorher haben sie bekommen
was sie suchten sind sie reingekommen
ich warne optiker drinnen das ging noch
aber wenn ich jetzt gucke und mahlbacher
und am rhein will oder bei den da immer
die läden die jetzt in teile zu machen
da ist man nicht so schnell drin wie man
möchte ja vor manchen geschäften ist es
tatsächlich so hendrik lange ihnen erst
mal von manchen geschäften ist es
tatsächlich so dass es dort
sicherheitspersonal gibt das den einlass
regelt und dass man teilweise eine halbe
bei manchen geschäften habe ich sogar
gehört eineinhalb stunden warten muss
bevor man reinkommt so sieht es
zumindest ihren der spitalerstraße aus
hier kommen so ein paar fragen über die
community rhein zum beispiel über
youtube fragt oder sagte dr clown
wunderbar und die sollen dann alle ein
meter fünfzig abstand halten das ist
fast unmöglich bei dem einkaufs wahnsinn
und auch über youtube fragt ein user
namens lupe ich frage mich warum so
etwas nicht bedacht wird da werden die
leute noch zwei tage vor dem lockdown
zusammengetrieben
es werden was sagen denn die leute die
du da heute getroffen hast warum sind
sie denn da unterwegs
also es gab ein sehr unterschiedliches
meinungsbild ganz häufig würde ich dass
die leute das in der tat ganz genauso
sehen dass man eigentlich hätte erwarten
können und vielleicht laufen nichts
gegen gehabt wenn man gestern schon
beschlossen hätte heute und morgen wird
hier gar nicht mehr geöffnet
lustigerweise wird man dann aber auch
gleich wieder wenn man die nächsten
schritte daneben stehen oder die nächste
das ist doch eigentlich sinnvoll ist
noch weihnachtsgeschenke zu kaufen und
natürlich sagen alle dass sie genügend
abstand halten
wenn man sich jetzt hier mal so
unkorrekt hier in dieser straße ist das
auch tatsächlich möglich vor manchen
einkaufs geschäften in manchen
einkaufspassagen und für manchen
einkaufspassagen hat sogar die polizei
auf abstands einhaltung gebracht und
nicht wenige sagen ja dass statt hier
ein ereignis ist bei dem eventuell noch
wieder neue ansteckungsquellen möglich
sind auch wenn das muss man natürlich
zur verteidigung der hanseaten sagen
alle sehr bedacht darauf sind den
abstand auf einzuhalten weil natürlich
möchte niemand hier seine letzten
weihnachtsgeschenke kaufen und sich
vielleicht noch ein virus mit unter den
tannenbaum legen wenn wie ist denn die
stimmung also ist das das hat
wahrscheinlich mit vorweihnachtlichem
ein einkaufserlebnis gar nicht viel zu
tun aber sind die leute gestresst weil
sie so schnell wie möglich rein und
wieder raus wollen und und aggressiv
weil es ihnen einfach selbst zu voll ist
obwohl sie ja teil des problems sind
oder wie würdest du das beschreiben also
zum einen muss ich natürlich sagen wir
sind hier in hamburg natürlich
irgendjemand gestressten und deswegen
scherz die leute dann nehme ich relativ
entspannt also wenn ich um mich mal rum
rick hendrick bestätigen sie mir dass
die leute sind entspannt ja erst nickt
mit dem kopf steht aber noch hier bei
mir nur deutschland entspannt alles was
damit zu tun oder wie haben sie das in
den geschäften erlebt in den geschäften
sind ich erstmal sich sehr dass es so
voll ist wirklich letzten wochen hat ja
nicht so toll aber ist alles relativ
entspannendes zu geben welches geschäft
eingeht ja man muss aber auch dazu sagen
das ist natürlich ein montag das heißt
eigentlich haben alle auch noch
gearbeitet heute und das heißt dass es
sich erst jetzt füllt heute morgen habe
ich schon ein paar leute getroffen die
gesagt haben wir sind extra so früh
gekommen damit wir möglichst um 10 uhr
45 schon mit dem einkauf fertig sind und
eben nicht mehr in eine volle innenstadt
müssen
aber wenn man sich anguckt in diese
richtung einen kilometer weiter ich
zeige es mal da drüben rüber da ist
engelberg gewonnen dann kommt das
hamburger rathaus und dahinter ist das
traditionshaus alsterhaus am
jungfernstieg amboss pole war
prachtboulevard die haben im laufe des
tages die pressemeldung herausgegeben
dass sie bis 22 uhr
weil auch das war ja eine überlegung der
politik zu sagen wenn wir schon nur
diese zwei tage haben und sich alles
bald dann in cern wir das ganze einkaufs
geschehen so dass man vielleicht sogar
rund um die uhr einkaufen kann
dazu sagt der deutsche
einzelhandelsverband ganz klar in die
nähe das ist mit unserem personal nicht
zu machen auch und jetzt kommt obwohl es
rechtlich von den laden schließt gesetz
her möglich wäre und die einzelnen
kommunen also hier in dem fall die stadt
hamburg sehr wohl die möglichkeit hätten
die laden schließt oder öffnungszeit so
zu verlängern das man eigentlich auch um
24 uhr noch einkaufen kann aber mal hand
aufs herz
das geht in hamburg irgendwie vom wetter
nicht und den vielen anderen
bundesländern geht es einfach deswegen
nicht weil die ausgangssperren gibt die
hier in hamburg aber noch nicht greifen
wenn es vielleicht auch eine frage noch
einmal an erich heister glaube ich denn
nur da bei dir hast und die sich die
einzelhändler stellen das ist eine
forderung weil man im moment nicht
nichts machen kann weil geschlossen ist
ab morgen abend ob man mit click &
collect zum beispiel die möglichkeit hat
als einzelhändler trotzdem dass man
online was bestellt und die leute kommen
dann vor ort hin und holen sich die
sachen ab ist das was was für den
einzelhandel in hamburg eine lösung wäre
und auch für kunden wie ein
gesprächspartner der sowas nutzen würde
oder kommt das gar nicht in frage
also zum einen haben das vor allem muss
die masken mal wieder hochziehen ich das
irgendwann die polizei kommt und diese
live übertragen beendet zum einen haben
natürlich die vielen kleinen geschäfte
in der peripherie das für sich als idee
entdeckt also unser buch laden um die
ecke macht das hat das auch im lockdown
also dem dem frühjahrs ereignis gemacht
dass man telefonisch vorbestellen konnte
eindringlich fragte das normal die idee
zu sagen dass man telefonisch oder
online
dass man dann zumindest die möglichkeit
hat noch im geschäft oder vorm geschäft
abzuholen
wer das was sie nutzen würden würde das
sinn machen ja auf jeden fall oder ich
mir momentan oder heutzutage schon
vertreten weil manche sachen muss man
halt wirklich noch im laden abholen
beziehungsweise auch anprobieren und so
weiter wer eine überlegung würde ich
wirklich in erwägung ziehen ja wie
halten sie es denn überhaupt mit dem
online-handel man muss ja ehrlicherweise
sagen 1 der hauptsorgen des
einzelhandelsverbandes ist dass nicht
nur das ereignis im frühjahr sondern
auch jetzt der shutdown dazu führen dass
noch mehr im einzelhandel ist und ich
habe heute gerade gehört dass die
zuwächse die der online handel im
frühjahr gemacht hat von denen man ja
immer dachte ja wenn die geschäfte
wieder öffnen gehen die zurück dass die
nicht zurückgegangen sind spricht dass
da ein großes geschäft aus den präsident
geschäften zurück gegangen ist in die
online geschäfte und das fürchtet man
auch jetzt wenn ab übermorgen die
geschäfte schließen
in realen sie es mit online und offline
einkauf er hat in diesem online einkauf
ist klar jungen generation kennt sich
mit technik aus wird mehr online zu
öffnen mehr online bestellen ist
einfacher geht schneller und so weiter
und so fort
aber ich glaube so präsenz leben die
kann man nicht einfach so in bestimmten
branchen kann man nicht einfach so
ersetzen
deswegen werden die auch wie hier in der
spitalerstraße manchmal erhalten bleiben
ob der einkaufenden zurückgeht oder der
verkauf zurück geht die einnahmen
zurückgehen
die statistiken kenne ich nicht genau
aber das ist kann natürlich möglich sein
es klar
ja man muss natürlich noch einen effekt
hin zu rechnen dass es für die
innenstädte so wie hier in hamburg
natürlich schlimm wäre wenn dann noch
mehr in den online handel ging
auch wenn das schon von den
einzelhandels verbänden genauso
gesteuert wird das auch diese geschäfte
hier um mich herum sind jetzt natürlich
nur große ketten wie man sieht aber auch
die kleinen einzelhändler etwas weiter
hier in den nebenstraßen dass die auch
an der digitalisierung teilnehmen und
zumindest das sagt der sprecher vom
handelsverband nord zumindest digital
präsent sind so dass man weiß das ist
das angebot gibt dieses kleid oder
dieses buch oder dieses geschenk einfach
telefonisch vorzubestellen und es dann
weiß ich nicht mittwochmorgen um 8
uhr wieder abzuholen das ist sicher eine
chance gerade auch für kleine geschäfte
genau darum geht es auch gerade hier bei
uns im chat waldi mit drei ihnen
schreibt über youtube warum geht man das
risiko ein start bei den leben zu
bestellen über die möglichkeiten habt
ihr ja gerade schon besprochen
eva maria bach schreibt über youtube der
gewinner ist amazon auch das habt ihr
gerade schon erörtert
dann schreibt über facebook julia anke
martin das geht doch nicht nur um
weihnachtseinkäufe manche kaufen auch
dinge die sie in den nächsten monaten
brauchen werden winterkleidung
haushaltsgeräte umzugs zu gehör und
renovierungs material aus den vier
wochen können auch drei bis vier monate
werden
hoffen wir mal dass das nicht der fall
ist und eine frage noch an euch beide
und zwar über den hinweis von maria und
junkersdorf über youtube hinweg nämlich
wie wäre es mit geschenken die man nicht
einkaufen muss fantasie statt shoppen
wie wäre es denn für euch beide da vor
ort mit einem selbst gebastelten
gutschein oder irgendeiner anderen
kreativen idee und wie weit seid ihr
beide denn mit ihren
weihnachtsgeschenken schon
also ich glaube ein bisschen aus dem
nähkästchen die weihnachtsgeschenke
haben wir tatsächlich ein bisschen
früher angefangen ich warne bei mir
davor dass wir aufs basteln
zurückgreifen da hätten spätestens meine
kinder dann gestreikt und eindeutig
gewusst dass es den weihnachtsmann nicht
gibt hendrik die frage die das internet
noch auftauchte wie halt hält man es mit
selbst gebastelten dingen wie
gutscheinen oder weil sie ein begabter
maler oder ein toller musiker sind so in
materielle geschenke wie halten sie es
damit
ich wünsche euch werden ich werde schöne
hat ist aber damit damit fährt man am
besten zu geben dafür ist weihnachten da
dafür die post dafür persönliche
geschenke materielle sachen sind halt
meistens relativ teuer würde ich mal
zugeben ich habe nicht mal eben so
schenken alle die geste zählt und dass
jetzt die charmante antwort und was
schenken sie wirklich so ich versuche
immer persönliche sachen auf jeden fall
die die passenden zu schenken weil den
rest kann dieses kaufen
ja das ist vielleicht ein argument den
rest kann man sich mehr oder weniger
selber kaufen und ich finde ja
persönlich aber da mag ich ein alter
romantiker sein weihnachten ist ja nach
wie vor das fest der liebe der familie
und der kinder das mit der familie wird
schwierig den abstand müssen wir alle
dieses jahr halten deswegen habe ich
meine großeltern schon mit dem
entsprechenden online zugang
ausgestattet so dass wir ziemlich ist
sie zumindest virtuell dazu holen können
und dann müssen sie es einfach ertragen
das ich dann auch online mal ein
bisschen singe so viele geschenke
die brauche ich auch nicht im laden zu
kaufen denn das wird eher ein
wunderbares weihnachtsfest bei der
familie riten
vielen herzlichen dank für diese
eindrücke aus der mönckebergstraße in
hamburg vielen dank und auch an seinen
gesprächspartner noch mal vielen dank
hier aus dem studio ja liebe
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer wir freuen
uns weiterhin über eure fragen und
kommentare wie immer an in die
kommentarspalten oder auch über die zdf
heute app an die bekannte adresse die
auch hier nochmal eingeblendet wird und
auch wenn das jetzt hinten raus einen
etwas humorigen tonfall bekommen hat wir
dürfen nicht vergessen dass wir wie ich
eingangs sagte in einer sehr ernsten
lage sind und natürlich stellt sich die
frage was bedeutet das wenn jetzt
samstag montag und dienstag noch so
unglaublich viele menschen in den
fußgängerzonen unterwegs sind für den
verlauf der pandemie
diese frage möchte ich gerne weitergeben
an professor thorsten leer er ist
professor für klinische pharmazie an der
universität des saarlandes in
saarbrücken und außerdem im expertenrat
der landesregierung für die kogit 19
pandemie und dass eben gerade erst eine
sitzung mit dem ministerpräsidenten zu
ende gegangen wenn ich das richtig
verstanden habe vielen dank dass sie
direkt hier zu uns hinüber gewechselt
hinter professor lehr
sie waren schon mal zu gast hier in der
sendung im stream weil sie einen kowitz
simulator programmiert haben den auch
jederzeit jeder im netz aufrufen kann
und simulieren kann anhand verschiedener
parameter wie sich was entwickelt je
nachdem welche maßnahmen ergriffen
werden können sie uns bevor wir über die
einzelnen
alle reden noch mal erklären wie das
genau funktioniert und welche werte sie
berücksichtigt haben in ihren
simulationen wir einen wunderschönen
abend und ja das wäre ich natürlich sehr
gerne wir haben diesen kugel simulator
entwickelt das ist ein mathematisches
modell was wir jetzt seit über acht
monaten hier an der universität des
saarlandes entwickeln wo wir die daten
verschiedene datenquellen von der panne
wie zusammenführen und dann in einem
mathematischen modell übertragen dort
gehen daten ein wie zum beispiel die
täglichen meldezahl vom
robert-koch-institut daten vom intensiv
register wir haben aber auch eine
datenbank von über 15.000 patienten warm
und sehr viele daten auch von den stadt
und landkreisen die uns dann
entsprechend auch zur verfügung gestellt
werden um dieses modell zu entwickeln
wir haben gerade schon gesagt man kann
das selber ausprobieren wir haben damit
wir das jetzt hier nicht noch mal alles
irgendwie zeigen müssen weil das relativ
viel zeit in anspruch nimmt
vorher schon mal besprochen über welches
fallzahlen wir sprechen wollen weshalb
sie uns dankenswerterweise schon ein
paar sachen durchgespielt haben und die
erste frage wäre tatsächlich wie sich
diese shopping tage habe ich ja gerade
schon erwähnt auf den verlauf der
pandemie auswirken und dazu gibt es
folgende grafik von ihnen die sie
erstellt haben die wir jetzt auch mal
zeigen können genau ich hoffe sie können
das auch sehen herr professor lehr und
uns ein bisschen erklären was wir hier
sehen kann was wir hier sehen ist erst
mal auf der auf der y-achse der linken
achse die hoch geht das ist die sieben
tages inzidenz de mal in aller munde ist
das heißt wie viele neue fälle haben wir
pro 100000 einwohner in sieben tagen
da liegen wir jetzt momentan relativ
hoch da legen wir ungefähr bei knapp
unter 200 180 190 die würde dann
entsprechend auch hier haben wir jetzt
das simulation szenario einmal
was würde passieren wenn wir einen
shopping event haben das heißt dass
jetzt alle noch mal sehr heftig shoppen
gehen und sich diese infektiosität in
dem zeitraum einfach nochmal erhöht das
ist quasi die rote kurve über die blauen
150 anfang dezember also ein bisschen
niedriger als wir jetzt aktuell sind
jetzt sind wir ja genau das ist aber
auch noch anfang dezember der lage waren
anfang dezember noch jetzt sind wir ja
schon ja quasi mitte dezember deswegen
ist das nur noch mal ein bisschen um die
vergangenheit mit abzubilden dass wir
wissen wo wir so gestartet sind im
dezember haben wir nämlich noch mal
einfach und relativ starken boost jetzt
erlebt die fallzahlen sind jetzt noch
mal relativ stark hochgegangen in dieser
adventszeit bedauerlicherweise haben das
ist auch das was wir jetzt hier sehen
dass wir einfach jetzt erstmal sehr
steilen anstieg haben das ist eben auch
gerade sehr bedenklich und wie gesagt
das rote wäre quasi wenn wir jetzt alle
sehr stark stoppen würden in den
nächsten vier tagen oder in vier tagen
oder drei tagen die jetzt quasi dafür
noch zur verfügung stehen oder standen
insgesamt genau dann würde letztendlich
die institute relativ stark ansteigen
würden ein maximum ungefähr bei einer
sieben tage sind sie denn das von 250
landen deutschlandweit da sind dann noch
so so schattierte felder hinten tragen
das ist letztendlich das der war der
unsicherheits bereich weil wir nicht
genau wissen wie sich das jetzt wirklich
auswirkt es gibt jetzt gar keine aus
unseren erkenntnissen keine
hundertprozentige evidenz welchen effekt
genauer haben deswegen haben wir hier
angenommen dass weder quasi zwischen 25
und 50 prozent mehr kontakt da haben wir
in dem zeitraum aber da hören wir sehen
dass die sind sehr stark ansteigt und
wenn wir quasi das shoppen ausgestellt
hätten so wie wir das jetzt
beispielsweise in sachsen gesehen haben
mit den bildern am anfang der sendung
dann wäre das gerade die blaue kurve bei
denen wir dann entsprechend haben ja ein
anstieg sehen würden wir jetzt eben
nicht mehr so stark wäre dann würde die
inzidenz bürgern geschätzt 200 an
stoppen und was wir dann noch sehen ist
hier noch mal so ein grauer balken
derzeit grauen balken der erste von oben
nach unten das hier wäre der erste das
ist quasi shopping jetzt je mehr leute
unterwegs sind desto höher steigt die
kurve dann im verlauf dieser shopping
events an und das zweite was sie
ansprechen das ist dieser bereich kann
auch das ist das ist weihnachten wir
gehen wir haben jetzt hier einfach mal
angenommen dass weihnachten sich
ungefähr so verhält wie shopping wenn
man das auf
teilweise sieht das auch wahrscheinlich
eine gerechtfertigte annahme auch hier
würden wir annahmen annehmen dass sich
die dass sich die kontakte ungefähr um
25 bis 50 prozent noch einmal erhöhen
würden und da sehen wir dadurch noch mal
klar machen nicht erhöhen weil das
shopping erlaubt wäre sondern einfach
weil mehr leute unterwegs sind um
weihnachten zu feiern also um
familienangehörige zu treffen und so
weiter also das ist quasi nur bewegung
insgesamt aber nicht bewegung wegen
shopping genau um letztendlich sind
beides kontakte das eine sind halt
kontakt den geschäften und im
öffentlichen leben und anderes im
privatbereich wir wissen einfach aus
anderen pandemien wie eben auch zb der
influenza das daher bat das
weihnachtsfest ein sehr starker treiber
ist weil wir sehen dass jetzt aus den
usa wo zum beispiel denkt skipping was
hier so ein äquivalent zu unseren
weihnachtsfest auch sehr stark die
zahlen in die höhe getrieben hat
deswegen ist es auch hier eben zu
vermuten dass zwischen diesen dass an
diesem zweiten grauen balken daneben
auch noch mal sehr starke kontakt und
infektion stattfinden das dann gilt es
eben jahr zu erwarten und das sollte
natürlich verhindern
und was wir dann dazwischen annehmen ist
letzte nicht dass wenn sehr harten
lockdown fahren würden wo der wert sich
dann entsprechend reduzieren würde und
die kontakte wir insgesamt um mehr
zwischen 40 und 60 prozent nochmal
reduzieren würden also ein sehr harten
faktoren wie man nicht erwarten würden
und eben das was wir gerade gesehen
haben ist dass die zahlen sich doch sehr
deutlich unterscheiden wenn wir halt
weihnachten würden in beiden fällen
feiern aber das shopping event wäre nur
in dem einen und dem anderen eben nicht
von daher kann ich nur an jeden
appellieren zu überlegen wie dann
vielleicht der morgige tag zu gestalten
ist noch bin ich wie gerade eben auch
gesehen vielleicht doch lieber schirme
und papier rausholen und was basteln
oder malen professor hier kommen zwei
fragen an sie und zwar von kai wolf über
youtube woher kommt die sicherheit dass
shopping events einen derart großen
einfluss haben in hinblick darauf dass
in deutschland gar nicht klar ist wo ein
großteil der infektionen her kommt
nämlich also wo ein großteil der
infektion hier ist die rede von 70
prozent schreibt kai wolf stattfinden
das ist die eine frage und die andere
schiebe ich einfach gleich hinterher auf
facebook fragt sandra net aufgrund der
simulation ist bis märz mindestens alles
dicht stimmt das
also ich vielleicht mal mit der ersten
die erste frage ist natürlich richtig
wir wissen nicht genau welche welchen
effekt diese diese shopping events
wirklich haben bei 70 prozent der
ereignisse nicht wissen wo die infektion
stattgefunden haben wir wissen sie immer
aus dem heimischen bereich weil sie dort
gut nachvollziehbar sind das ist klar
wir müssen aber einfach davon ausgehen
wird es bei dieser hohen mobilität und
bei diesen hohen kontakten wie sie jetzt
stattfinden auch in dieser situation wo
wir uns gerade befinden haben sehr sehr
wahrscheinlich ist dass dort auch eben
übertragung am stattfinden werden
natürlich haben lediglich haben alle
geschäfte gene konzepte trotzdem haben
wir einfach auch eine vergangenheit
gesehen ist diese hygiene konzepte
möglicherweise hat einfach nicht
ausreichend was wir halten an neben ist
einfach ein gewisses szenario weil wir
es nicht genau wissen um einfach mal
darauf hinzuweisen dass es eine
möglichkeit ist deswegen haben wir auch
ein relativ breites band für diesen
shopping event weil wir eben nicht genau
wissen wie stark diese kontakte wirklich
sein werden aber wir wissen es teilweise
noch aus amerikanischen studien wo eben
auch diese einkaufs
einkaufsgelegenheiten eben auch
übertragungswege sind aber das ist
natürlich kann man ihm argumentieren
dass amerika nicht deutschland ist aber
trotzdem warum haben wir dass dort eben
gesehen deswegen ist das hier
entsprechend die annahme und der die
erhöhung der kontakte ist auch nicht
nicht sehr stark das muss man einfach
dazu sagen trotzdem ist der effekt sehr
groß weil wir uns gerade in einer sehr
luftigen höhe befinden das heißt in
zahlen sind gerade sehr groß die
durchseuchung sozusagen es relativ hoch
deshalb ist hier eine kleine steigerung
letztendlich hat eine relativ große
wirkung und die zweite frage ist
letztendlich natürlich auch eine mit dem
wir uns auseinandersetzen müssen ist wie
lange hält das denn eigentlich an jetzt
haben wir hier natürlich durch die
shopping events oder nicht shopping
events und weihnachten auch eine gewisse
verlängerung
aber nichtsdestotrotz auch sind wenn
selbst wenn wir annehmen dass keine
shopping events und dadurch keine
infektion stattfinden dann gilt
natürlich immer noch die blaue kurve und
wenn wir uns da die durchgezogene linien
der mitte anschauen dann sehen wir dass
sie diese 50 tage incidents
möglicherweise nicht am 10 januar wie es
von der politik über proklamiert wird
durchbrechen sondern halte
möglicherweise erst zu einem späteren
zeitpunkt also das essen müssen wir uns
bewusst sein und das ist einfach wichtig
dass wir uns da möglicherweise
darauf einstellen wie gut dass
letztendlich funktioniert und wann wir
diese linie durchbrechen diese gelb
eingezeichnete fünf incidents linie
hängt natürlich auch sehr stark davon ab
wie gut wir uns jetzt eigentlich selber
zügeln können und ja uns einfach an die
abstand zu jener alltags masken und
lüftungs gebot erhalten werden dann
würde ich gerne mal eine grafik weiter
gehen sozusagen manfred küster fragt
nämlich über facebook die ergebnisse von
heute wird man in zehn bis 14 tagen und
dann an silvester auf den
intensivstationen sehen können und auch
dazu haben sie uns eine grafik geschickt
hier kann man sehen was quasi die folgen
sind dessen was wir jetzt tun oder nicht
tun können sie das noch mal erklären was
wir jetzt hier vorliegen haben wir
professoren ja ganz klar das ist jetzt
quasi die übertragung in die belegung
der intensivbetten deutschlandweit was
wir hier sehen momentan sind wir
ungefähr 4.500 bis 4600 betten also wir
befinden uns ungefähr schon in ihrem
ersten grauen balken dann befinden wir
uns ja jetzt schon drin
das heißt da sind wir gerade ungefähr
selbst wenn wir den locker und jetzt
sofort fahren und das muss uns einfach
bewusst sein selbst wenn wir jetzt quasi
ab mittwoch quasi alle zu hause bleiben
wird die belebung auf den
intensivstationen es drei bis vier
wochen später ihr maximum erreichen
das heißt also hier werden wir
eigentlich erst im januar silvester war
schon guter zeitrahmen wirklich sehen
dass wir das dem peak erreichen dass
kommen bisschen darauf an wie viel neue
fälle wird es durch das shopping event
durch weihnachten möglicherweise
generieren aber wir würden hier ein
relativ steilen anstieg noch sehen wo
wir dann irgendwo zwischen 5 und 7
tausend belegten intensivbetten belegen
würden in einer ist sagte meine im
schlimmsten szenario und da müssen wir
natürlich auch schauen dass jetzt nicht
nur die verzögerung
das erreichen dieser 50er inzidenz werde
eine rolle spielt sondern eben auch was
macht das gesundheitswesen und da müssen
wir halt eben daran denken dass wir
damit jetzt nicht nur mehr
intensivbetten belegen sondern dass das
am ende des tages natürlich auch haben
die sterblichkeit in dieser
patientenpopulation dann nach oben
treiben wird
nun gibt es ja viel kritik auch an den
zahlen mathematische berechnungen sind
ihr kerngeschäft aber was ist wenn es
schon an der grundlage dazu quasi kritik
gibt ich habe mal drei gesammelt die ich
alleine heute gefunden habe
stefan willich direktor am institut für
epidemiologie an der charité berlin sagt
diese 50 diese zahl 50 dieser incidents
wert den sie gerade genannt haben der
ist aus ärztlicher sicht nicht wirklich
belastbar
weil sie eine mischung aus zufalls
gefunden und freiwilligen test um
widerspiegelt die dunkelziffer ist viel
zu hoch
andreas gassen vorstandsvorsitzender der
kassenärztlichen bundesvereinigung sagt
dasselbe
diese 50 neuinfektionen pro 100000
einwohner stammen aus einer zeit in der
es wöchentlich 400.000 tests gab und die
positive rate hoch war
inzwischen wird dreimal so viel getestet
bei viel weniger test positiven und
letzte meinung dazu fresenius chef
stephan sturm schreibt der einzige der
einseitige fokus der politik auf die
intensivbetten ist falsch weil es nicht
nur um die intensivbetten geht sondern
auch ob die menschen die überhaupt diese
patienten versorgen können
nun sind das aber nur weil die zahlen
die auf dem markt sind und mit denen sie
arbeiten wie gehen sie denn mit der
kritik an diesen zahlen um
also ich meine das ist jetzt erst mal
eine kritik an den mast zahlen in der
politik auch verwendet werden das ist
jetzt erst mal keine kritik an unseren
modellen haben ich glaube wir müssen
einfach schauen dass wir gewisse werte
einfach verwenden die dann halt einfach
auch möglicherweise leicht verdaubar
sind also weil sich eine 15 7 tages in
the dance ist leicht verständlich oder
mehr oder weniger leicht verstellen ist
wir schauen uns in unserem simulator
natürlich jetzt auch nicht nur die fälle
die inzidenz sondern halt eben natürlich
auch die belegung auf den sieg betten an
also man muss sicherlich schon mehr sich
anschauen und natürlich auch den erwerb
als einen wichtigen faktor viii denn
gerade die infektions lagen ist also ich
denke wir müssen in der summe 1 1 ein
gesamtheitliches bild einfach abdecken
aber ich denke schon dass diese
incidents lage in der wir uns gerade
befinden dass wir jenseits dieser
fünfziger grenze sind dass das natürlich
sehr kritisches wir haben das einfach
mal untersucht zu beginn der zweiten
welle und sehen dort eigentlich dass bei
ungefähr so ab 2000 täglichen fällen mit
so einer art breakthrough haben das
heißt dass er als für ungefähr 2000
tägliche fälle deutschlandweit hatten
ist das system anscheinend kollabiert
ein bisschen aus den fugen geraten und
haben die inzidenz ist eigentlich ein
bisschen niedriger dort als die 5
50er insidious thema genannt wird also
ich glaube wir müssen das ganzheitlich
anschauen und noch mal einen punkt auch
zu den positiv raten also die positiv
haben sind momentan aktuell wirklich
wieder sehr hoch wir haben wenn nicht
sogar ein allzeithoch gerade auch bei
den positiv warten obwohl wir relativ
viel testen was eben daran liegt dass
wir auch eine veränderte test strategie
haben das dürfen wir nicht vergessen
ich glaube auch dass momentan die test-
oder die dunkelziffer höher ist als sie
vorher war sie drei oder vier wochen
eben nur noch patienten patienten testen
die symptome zeigen die nicht
symptomatischen patienten das heißt die
keine reaktion zeigt nach dem kontakt
mit einem kugel patient wenn ja gar
nicht mehr getestet
in unserem modell ist das implizit auch
mit eingebaut dass durch die testate
letztendlich halt auch reflektiert wird
das heißt die höhe die positiv-test rate
um so höher gehen wir davon aus dass
dann auch die patienten erkrankt sind
unsere mehr gehen davon auch ins
krankenhaus das heißt also wir
berücksichtigen dass schon die sich
verändernde strategie sind natürlich
auch nicht glücklich mit gewöhnen auch
lieber jeden testen aber wir müssen
natürlich einfach irgendwo auch
ressourcen schonend an das gesamte
gesundheitssystem denken hier fragen
sich im chat viele leute das ist
eigentlich jetzt streng genommen keine
frage an sie als als wissenschaftler
aber ich stelle sie trotzdem mal denn
sie haben sicher auch eine einschätzung
ohne meinung dazu ronny becker schreibt
zum beispiel über youtube warum schließt
man die öffentlichen verkehrsmittel
nicht
da kann man natürlich sagen das wäre
sinnvoll das zu machen einfach damit
sich die leute dann nicht nach dem
weihnachts shopping noch eng zusammen in
die s-bahn stellen auf der anderen seite
ist es natürlich für ein land
unerlässlich dass es eine
funktionierende infrastruktur gibt und
wenn man plötzlich feststellen würde das
die nicht mehr funktioniert dann würde
das wahrscheinlich zu noch mehr panik
führen als sie in manchen teilen der
bevölkerung ja schon da es und das ist
ja nicht so dass man das einschränken
muss denn die fahrer der s-bahn und die
schaffner und sie sind ja alle im
einsatz es ist ja nicht so dass die
infrastruktur gefährdet wäre aber
natürlich könnte man sagen wenn sie
nicht fahren würden all diese busse und
bahnen während zwangsweise weniger leute
unterwegs
ja ganz genau also ich denke das ist
jetzt einfach auch wichtig weil das wir
anfangs schon sagt wir wissen eigentlich
gar nicht wo die infektionen wirklich
stattfinden
manche bilder aus u bahn oder aus dem
öffentlichen personennahverkehr
anschauen würde es mich jetzt nicht
wundern wenn dort auch natürlich
infektion stattfänden
das ist quasi unerlässlich bei der enge
die da teilweise stattfindet aber es
gibt halt einfach kein nachweis aber nur
weil das kein nachweis gibt heißt
natürlich nicht dass es dort nicht
stattfindet haben da fehlt einfach an
studien und natürlich auch an der
möglichkeit dass die korona app
beispielsweise auch bestimmt an welchen
ort diese infektionen stattgefunden
haben das ist aber natürlich
datenschutztechnisch nicht einfach aber
was wir natürlich schon aussehen und das
sehen wir eben auch in manchen anderen
events wie zum beispiel schulschließung
ist dass er jetzt auch nicht nur dadurch
die schulen zum beispiel beschlossen
werden sondern dass eben auch der pnv
zum beispiel zurückgefahren wird
weil natürlich die schülerinnen und
schüler nicht mehr fahren die eltern
müssen vermehrt ins home office ist
gefahr nämlich die gesamte mobilität
zurück und das ist auch das was wir
einfach in der ersten welle gesehen
haben beim ersten lockdown dass sich
dieser mobilitäts index natürlich sehr
stark reduziert hat dort haben wir die
mobilität um ungefähr 40 prozent
eingeschränkt momentan sind wir bei er
so zehn prozent reduktion der mobilität
und ich bin sehr gespannt wie diese
mobilitäts daten jetzt für diese 34
shopping tage aussehen die wir jetzt in
den vergangenen tagen und noch kommenden
tag morgen haben werden weil ich mir
sehr gut vorstellen kann dass das immer
auch wieder nach oben schnellt und diese
mobilität ist letztendlich wieso naht
fieberkurve das heißt das ist natürlich
irgendwie das ist nicht das ist
letztendlich eine eine reflektion des
des symptoms das heißt das ist nicht die
ursache sondern das zeigt uns noch was
letztendlich an kontakt stattfindet über
die mobilität und das müssen wir einfach
jetzt versuchen einzuschränken und
deswegen hat auch natürlich die bitte zu
hause zu bleiben wo es nicht aber man
anders geht und er einfach das
besinnliche weihnachten vielleicht im
kleinen sehr familiären kreis die feier
nun ist eine frage die auch gestern
schon gestellt wurde bei der
pressekonferenz nach dem treffen der
ministerpräsidenten und der
bundeskanzlerin
warum hat man das nicht schon viel
früher gemacht warum hat man statt dem
lockdown leid im november nicht schon im
november harte maßnahmen ergriffen
dann hätten wir jetzt nicht das problem
das wir jetzt haben die politik hat
gestern gesagt es macht jetzt keinen
sinn im nachhinein zu sagen wir hätten
das so und so machen müssen wir blicken
nach vorne aber aus ihrer sicht auch sie
haben das mal berechnet und
das können wir uns anschauen was wäre
wenn wir zum einen mit dem lockdown leid
weiter gemacht hätten und was wäre wenn
wir schon früher mit dem harten lockdown
begonnen hätten können sie noch mal
erklären was wir hier sehen
ja das ist letztendlich auch eine kurve
die wir auch dann letztendlich auch
unsere landesregierung noch anderen zur
verfügung gestellt haben weil wir
endlich genau das zeigen wollten dass
wenn wir nur wenn wir wirklich
erfolgreich und hat diesen lockdown
fahren würden dass wir dann in dieser
vorgegebene zeit und im november aber ja
noch dann die sprache davon dass wir
dann ende november wieder lockern würden
da war eigentlich schon klar dass das
nicht funktioniert wir können gerne auch
gleich darüber sprechen warum man das
vorher trotzdem nicht gemacht hat was
bildet sich sehen die rote kurve ist
letztendlich so wie es ungefähr auch
weiter gegangen ist das war damals eine
annahme dass wir gesagt haben okay wir
haben zu einer reduktion aber es ist
vielleicht nicht ausreichend das steigt
ist immer noch weiter an und genau das
ist schon keine kurve mehr ist schon
fast eine linie wäre gewesen wenn wir
einfach nicht den harten lockdown
beschlossen hätten sondern mit dem lock
downlight weitergemacht hätte nicht und
da sind wir jetzt endlich dann jetzt
leider auch gelandet das heißt es ist
vielleicht am anfang ein bisschen grader
gegangen aber dann zum schluss deutlich
steiler hoch die blaue linie wäre jetzt
eine kontakt reduktion gewesen hoffen
denn er wird von 0,8
das wäre ungefähr eine halbierung dass
das dass der kontakte gewesen die wir
vor dem lock downlight hatten und die
grüne linie wäre ein eher wert von 0,6
das ist ungefähr der wert den wir
erreicht hatten während des ersten
harten lockdown dort das war auch ein
eher wert den wir in anderen ländern
gesehen haben also italien frankreich
spanien sollte es auch der die kontakte
dann entsprechend zurückgegangen und was
man halt sieht ist dass sie sehe nicht
wie beim auto ist ja es gibt zwei wenn
sie das bremsen wollen das hat eine
fahrt drauf dann gibt es da zwei
komponenten das eine ist wie hart steige
ich auf die bremse das ist der wert das
heißt kleiner der wert umso härter
bremse ich sozusagen und die zweite
frage ist komme ich vorher waren auch
zum stehen hängt noch davon ab wie hoch
ist meine geschwindigkeit und die
inzidenz ist letztendlich ein maß für
die geschwindigkeit das heißt habe ich
eine inzidenz auch ich länger aber ich
hier niedrigere geht schneller das heißt
wir werden einfach natürlich schneller
aus diesem szenario werde er ausgewiesen
wenn wir diesen
lockdown im november sehr stark gefahren
werden und das kann man jetzt natürlich
beschwichtigen und sagen das was
interessiert mich mein geschwätz von
gestern
aber ich glaube wir müssen uns schon
noch mal die frage stellen warum man
eigentlich denn im november immer wieder
wo die zeichen deutlich darauf
hingedeutet haben dass eine verschärfung
nötig gewesen wäre man immer wieder
gesagt hätten aber wir warten noch mal
bewerben noch mal und dann sind wir
natürlich in die missliche bredouille
gekommen dass das advents und
weihnachtsgeschäft gestartet hat das
natürlich für den einzelhandel der
logitech lukrativ war also mit denen mit
einem haben lockt im november behaupte
ich mal hätten wir mit einem klugen und
gene konzept auch im dezember
wahrscheinlich den etwa etwas normaler
vollführen können als wir den jetzt seit
einigen wochen herumeiern sozusagen die
frage nach dem klugen konzept die stellt
tatsächlich auch kein wolf über youtube
wenn sie herr professor lehr einen
vorschlag für eine gute präventive
maßnahme hätten welche bisher noch nicht
beachtet wurde
welche wäre das ja das ist natürlich
sehr schwierig ich glaube eine wichtige
tatsache die oder eine wichtiges
instrument was uns jetzt zur verfügung
steht sind einfach schnelltests die
müssen wir jetzt einfach flächendeckend
versuchen zu implementieren und eben
auch nicht medizinisches personal
schulen und dadurch sind wir einfach in
der lage auch bei dieser hohen inzidenz
lager auch werden vielleicht die
sensitivität nicht so toll ist trotzdem
falsch positiven zu identifizieren und
damit zum beispiel auch das eintragen in
wohlrabe gruppen wie alt das und alten
und pflegeheime zu verhindern das ist
erstmal glaube ich haben das
allerwichtigste dass wir die alten und
gefährdeten sehr stark schützen
ich denke wir müssen einfach jetzt uns
überlegen haben auch die erkenntnisse
aus der ersten welle mitzunehmen wir
wissen eben auch beispielsweise von
verschiedenen studien aus amerika die
gezeigt haben dass zum beispiel auch
restaurants bars und andere
im jahr institution des treffens endlich
auch wieder problemlos eröffnen können
wenn du die belegung nicht so groß ist
also wenn man anstatt einer
hundertprozentigen belegung in einem
restaurant also 20 bis 25 prozent der
fläche bedingt also also sage ich sehr
logisch dass dieser abstand und hygiene
regeln müssen einfach wieder eingehalten
werden
wir müssen uns halt einfach jetzt
bewusst machen dass wir auch in dieser
zeit leben wo wir nicht mehr draußen auf
dem marktplatz letztendlich unser
training zu uns nehmen sondern halt
jemand in geschlossenen räumen auch da
muss dann halt wieder gelüftet werden
und ich denke dass viele gaststätten das
auch gut umgesetzt haben aber es gab
natürlich wahrscheinlich einige schwarze
schafe aber das ist jetzt sehr schwierig
retrospektiv aus zu finden also ich
glaube dass kluge konzepte sehr
schwierig wir müssen glaube ich an
verschiedenen stellschrauben und sein
fach orientieren aber als erstes mal
eben auch ein einsatz von von
massentests und damit halt auch wirklich
der schutz eben von den gefährdeten
gruppen wie eben vor allem die älteren
mitbürgerinnen mitbürger und warum das
bislang noch nicht so gelungen ist wie
sich das eigentlich viele oder alle
wünschen würden das ist noch mal ein
thema für einen eigenen stream den wir
ganz bestimmt auch noch mal im verlauf
dieser pandemie die ja noch lange nicht
zu ende sein wird machen werden
lieber herr professor lehr ganz vielen
herzlichen dank dass sie sich die zeit
genommen haben heute abend für uns danke
liebe userinnen und user für die
konstruktive teilnahme und einen schönen
abend noch und bis bald
[Musik]